and you've been on the East Coast for a
long time yeah good afternoon and
welcome to at Yale live I'm Eric Gershon
today we talk economics with a king of
the field Robert chase Shiller sterling
professor of economics and a winner of
the 2013 Nobel Prize in Economics as
always we'll take some of your questions
submit them via Twitter to at Yale or by
email to social media Eddie led you
you can also Facebook us Bob Shiller
thanks so much for being here
my pleasure so if I'm not mistaken you
are recently returned from the World
Economic Forum in Davos Switzerland what
did you take who did you meet what was
interesting to you how was the
experience it was a day-long experience
for most of a week I met I can't
remember all the people I met it's a
like a cocktail party that extends all
day I met the Mayor of London Boris
Johnson
I met the CEO of Morgan Stanley James
Gorman I can go on lots of people what
were what were some of the most
memorable uh moments for you I don't
know the thing that strikes me is the
general mood of the event and what
struck me most was how it changed
abruptly midweek with the Argentine peso
problem and the feeling I got is it wow
this is a big world crisis but I think I
was talking to too many economists then
when I got back nobody seemed worried
about Argentina not many people now was
that young relatively new Argentinian
finance minister there himself do you
know I don't know it was like everybody
talking about it I didn't I didn't see
him so I don't there are lots of heads
of state there but generally I didn't
encounter them they came with their
entourage as you can see when a big
crowd moved through the room it's the
prime minister in the center
and you can't even see him because
there's so many people reporters and
they're like following them now did I
understand that you you tried on Google
glass well yeah how was that oh it was
exciting you know I had never even seen
them before and it's a little trip into
the future I imagine that we'll all be
wearing something them like that someday
and you can just look up and get
information it would be maneras me we
talked a lot about the future and this
is something that others have comes it
on at Davos it wasn't so much about well
it was about Argentina but beyond that
it was a lot about where are we going
with all this new technology and what
kind of world will we have in 20 30
years and how will young people today
prosper in that world that that's a real
problem
mm-hmm you are originally from Michigan
if I'm not mistaken correct and that
reminds me of a story that you told on
the day that you won the Nobel Prize
just a few months ago if and it correct
me if I get any of this wrong but you
called up your brother in Michigan and
you say and you said did you hear and he
said yeah the Tigers lost that's exactly
right and was he was he had he not heard
or was he just pulling your leg he had
not heard well I called him up pretty
quickly you know I got a call at 6:30 in
the morning and it wasn't long
afterwards that I called him yeah so
it's entirely possible that he hadn't
seen the news yet that's that's pretty
funny so you were you were already a
very prominent globally prominent
economist before you won the Nobel Prize
you've since won the Nobel Prize has has
the additional renown changed your life
in any particular way well I hope this
is temporary I've had to declare an
email bankruptcy that means I don't feel
that I can repay all the debts when
people write me I should write back but
I just can't
yeah so I'm hoping the other thing that
really strikes me is people come up to
me and say I'm honored to meet you and
nobody ever said that
before it's the pride first this is
clearly among academic prizes the number
one prize and I can feel it I can really
feel the difference yeah has has it
sparked any new relationships that you
expect I don't know to lead to projects
you hadn't considered before well I'm
getting contact you know I'm on
somebody's list and so I'm getting I'll
be on a lot of lists you know
politicians not just from this country
but around the world that will have
their aid or someone contact me with
they well that's just like asking for
advice or maybe they want me as a
trumpet for some of their advice mm-hmm
so we respect we're gonna get a number
of fairly detailed questions about
specific aspects of the economy in
business in the course of the show but I
want to ask initially for your your
big-picture view of the economy as we
see it right now at the beginning of
2014 the bright spots the concerns and
what's on your mind well I tend to think
about the long term not just about this
year and the issue that comes I've
already alluded to it is rising
inequality and the well I guess there's
this social we had a session at Davos
about the world in 50 years I left
feeling anxious and sweaty palms what is
it going to be like because we have this
problem of rising inequality largely
connected to rising technology
artificial intelligence replacing people
but it's more than that there's a lot of
issues going the future is just unknown
one thing is global warming but there
may be other environmental catastrophes
and something very negative here now try
to be positive this technology is moving
fast ly rapidly forward and it's
changing the world for the better so far
I want to see as an economist that it
stays that way that
that it doesn't impoverish whole
segments of the world or cause nations
to decline that you know are to hang in
there and benefit from the prosperity
mm-hmm you're obviously very famous for
the concept of financial bubbles and I
wonder if you could talk a little bit
first define it because it's it's a term
I think a lot of people think they
understand or have a notion of but you
may have a more specific definition and
then maybe talk a little bit about some
of the the most interesting bubbles that
you've studied and what you have found
so illustrative about them well the term
bubble if you look it up in the
dictionary it will say something like a
speculative bubble is a an instance
where prices of some speculative asset
are rising rapidly but for no good
reason
like filled with air the price rise it's
filled with air like a bubble that's not
that's not a good enough definition and
in my case in my opinion so I wrote my
own definition in a book I wrote called
irrational exuberance and there you've
got it right there I could read it from
that but I won't
paraphrasing my own definition I think
the essential idea within the bubble is
feedback that is prices go up and it
feeds back into investor demand and they
then they see prices going up and
expecting them to go up further they buy
into the market and push prices up again
and then this repeats itself in an
upward cycle but I have to go on beyond
that because in order to understand what
a bubble really is it's also a
psychological phenomenon that people are
not just extrapolating price increases
and buying in because they expect more
but they actually feel a positive
excitement a sort of gamblers excitement
which is contagious a bubble is
something like an epidemic but it's not
a disease epidemic it's a social
epidemic that goes on for some time
but it can't go on forever and
eventually it has to stop because the
man gets huge only because people think
that prices will keep going up but they
can't keep going up forever and when
they stop then they have the risk of
falling and the bubble bursts and and is
of the of the bubbles that you've
studied over the you know you can
historical bubbles are there some that
have proven especially interesting and
relevant perhaps today well the recent
bubbles there's two of them well there's
the stock market bubbles that's more
than one recently and there's housing
market bubbles we had a huge boom in the
stock market in the late 1990s the
peaked in 2000 then it went up it
bottomed out in 2003 that went up again
until 2007 and then it crashed bottomed
out in 2009 and it's been going up these
are like consecutive bubbles I would say
and in the housing market starting in
around the late 1990s until 2006 now we
can go back and find earlier examples
1929 is the most famous of them but I
don't know maybe the most recent example
is the most important and actually those
recent examples in the 2000s have
resurrected the word bubble
people weren't even using the word very
much until just after 2000 now it's
respectable used to be that people said
oh you know scientific research and
finance have proved that markets are
efficient and there are no bubbles yeah
I mean your your fellow Nobel winner
this year Eugene Feynman from the
University of Chicago I think I've read
or heard him say that he doesn't know
what a bubble is and I assume you've had
this conversation with him a number of
times
various various venues but if I'm gonna
take a question from a viewer now on the
same topic so you simply warned that
specula you being you Bob Shiller
recently more in speculative
we're emerging in the housing sector in
different parts of the world especially
in Brazil right and asks you know if
there are particular actions that
Brazilian policymakers should take at
this point and more broadly what would
be the implications for other emerging
markets if if they don't do anything
there isn't a science to controlling
bubbles it's a little bit like can you
know there's a mental illness called
manic depressive psychosis and we now
know that lithium works as a drug but we
don't have and it works in perfectly in
that case we don't have drugs like that
for speculative bubbles and we're
reliant on therapy of a more basic sort
there's many things that governments
have been doing to limit bubbles they
can put limits on loan on the amount of
loans that are given out by banks they
can put restrictions against buying a
second home and and you know our own
dodd-frank Act in 2010 created some
measures that will help prevent bubbles
but again you never know when these
things are adequate because the the
bubble phenomenon is essentially
psychological and you know it's like
trying to control a crowd if you have an
angry mob outside your door what
scientific method can I use to control
them well there really isn't any you can
try to talk to them and maybe it will
work maybe it won't you mentioned
inequality earlier in the in our chat
and it's it's it's a question that's
much in the news it sounds like it's a
topic that's on your own mind a fair
amount I'm going to take a question from
a Gail Dreyfus who writes to ask if the
excess wealth of the top 1% of Americans
were distributed more equally would it
make a significant difference to
everyone else or would everyone receive
such a small share that it wouldn't it
wouldn't make any difference at all well
that's a good question the
wealth of the household sector in the
United States is something like fifty
trillion dollars I don't have the latest
value divide that by 300 million I can't
do that in my head but it's enough to
yeah if they were to completely average
that out it would be enough to you know
provide a house for every individual
it's it's a it's a lot of money but it's
not super a lot in the sense that the
average of the median household already
has something like fifty thousand
dollars a year income it doesn't compare
with that the other thought about
redistributing all of this wealth after
the fact that means after people if some
people have spent their lifetimes
earning it and some people have been
diligent and saving there's a real
problem with that I don't think we can
do that we have to make adjustments that
go forward and respect what people have
already done now I know that there's
anger about some people who have made
huge portions out of business dealings
that really weren't productive and
helpful to society but we do live in our
country with a rule of law and you don't
just take something away from someone
who made the money illegally but that
said I think that we as a nation going
forward should think about what kind of
incentives we create what kind of
opportunities we allow for amassing
wealth and I think the focus should be
on the future hmm I mean implicit in
that question from Gail is is is the
question well does it really matter if
it if it doesn't if it wouldn't
redistribute if it wouldn't affect the
lives of everyone else in a significant
way in what sense does it actually
matter that there's this great
inequality and obviously there's an
important perhaps primary moral
dimension to it but I don't know if you
have yeah there is a moral dimension
that some people are struggling to get
by and that changes the whole feeling
our society I think we are a nation we
have a sense of community and we have to
we care about each other I think that
even for the richest people they don't
want to see a society where there are
starving children on the street did we
don't want that I wouldn't want that I
don't think that anyone wants that so
there has to be some sharing now one
element of sharing is philanthropy and
one thing that we're seeing for example
Bill Gates and Warren Buffett have a
so-called Giving Pledge campaign they're
trying to encourage wealthy people to
give their wealth charity or to
philanthropy and that's that's part of
the probably [ __ ] we're a little bit
stronger than it is but that's part of
the process of it's not all the
government that would help restore it
ultimately belongs to the people because
the people elect their government and
they also take on their own personal
measures to help alleviate poverty now
correct me if I'm wrong but I believe
you've said that that it is a moral
obligation of the rich to give away
money do I have that right right I am
actually chiming in with Andrew Carnegie
who wrote a book over a hundred years
ago called the Gospel of wealth and what
is the gospel of wealth
it's exactly what you said it's all
right to make a lot of money but before
you die you should give most of it away
constructively back to humanity and I
that's what I've asked my students to do
right I was even thinking of having them
sign a pledge in class but then I
decided that's being a little too
heavy-handed so I didn't but I tell them
that that it doesn't make any sense to
amass a billion dollars and then just
what are you gonna do with a billion
there's nothing you can only drive one
car at a time you don't live in one
house at a time if you've got twenty
houses that's kind of silly right
because you're only consuming one
and it's really really better if one
gives back to society now you can do
that incidentally I tell my students you
are under no obligation to make money
you can give back to society by taking
some very low paying job and I think
that's just as noble as what I mentioned
Bill Gates and Warren Buffett are doing
so do you think that there's sort of
have you ever imagined a number a
percentage that that you would imagine
as the the sort of morally just to give
away yeah well the Bible and the Quran
and other religious texts say 10% of
your income every year on the other hand
Buffett and Gates said 50% of your
accumulated wealth
hmm so I haven't tried to give another
number
I'm impressed with anyone who gives away
50 percent of their wealth on retirement
I'm gonna take another question on onion
equality and this is from Randy who asks
why has income equality increased after
both the dot-com and housing bubbles
shouldn't bubbles have a larger impact
on those with more invested it's an
interesting point so I'm not sure it has
the larger impact and people who who are
more invested because there they are
often they have good advice and they
hedge risks and protect themselves a lot
of the inequality that we speak of is
income inequality not wealth inequality
there's a distinction and a lot of the
inequality that we see is at the top 1%
or the top tenth of 1% it seems like our
modern economy is producing
opportunities for people in business to
make huge sums of money and that's
that's and it's it's partly because of
information technology
partly because of globalization so you
can take a business that's making a
little bit of money fire the workers in
America transfer your production to
China do some operations like that and
you can make huge amounts of money I'm
not even saying that's a bad thing to do
I guess it hurts Americans it helps
Chinese but but the point is that it
makes you the manager really wealthy IT
I've been teaching finance at Yale to
undergraduates for 25 years and I tell
them that finance is a very powerful
technology that's I think why so many of
the richest people involve themselves in
it at least partially but you have a
moral obligation as someone who's who's
acquired those skills to give back to
society in one way or another you spoke
of your students a few moments ago and
and and of course the course that you've
been teaching for a long time here at
Yale you're about to bring that to a
much larger audience than you've ever
been able to do before when you start
later this month
teaching a Coursera course a massive
open online course on financial markets
mm-hmm that is the course that you've
been teaching or a course you've been
teaching at Yale for I don't know two
decades or something like that tell us a
little bit about why of all the courses
you've taught over the years that's the
one that you wanted to start with well I
think I like finance what Yale is not
strong on vocational studies we don't
teach shorthand
we don't teach massage therapy we don't
teach Social Work not as a you know not
as preparing you for a job but I think
people do have to think about what they
can do and many of our students will
later go into a graduate program to
learn some of those skills that I
mentioned but I think that my course is
it's a mixture of learning about the
world and also learning useful skills I
believe I don't have any statistics
I believe that my students who take this
course
are very successful on the job market
and they move into important positions
so I'm proud of my list of alumni but
it's not me it's the technology finance
is a technology for getting things done
it's about financing some people think
it's about making money
I don't well maybe that's part of it but
I think of it instead as financing
activities our society our civilization
is built on organizations more than on
individual people just about everybody
belongs to some kind of organization
usually a company and that company
exists only according to the rules of
finance
that's why finance is so central it's
about creating organizations that
fulfill purposes long lived
organizations people come and go within
the organization the organization lives
on because it has a financial structure
that defines it I think that knowing
this technology is really important not
just for people who want to specialize
in finance but to anyone who wants to
have influence on our society who wants
to do something that makes a mark on our
society you have to appreciate finance
because it is how we get big things done
now as I understand there's something
like a hundred thousand people who've
already registered for in the course
which I believe starts February 17 right
other than the mode of delivery will
these people have an experience that at
least from a Content perspective is very
similar to the course that you teach you
know in person here you well we followed
Coursera guidelines yeah the course is a
little bit shorter it's divided up into
shorter segments not I have these hour
and 15 minute lectures here so we
divided up into something more like 20
minutes per lecture and I've tried to
make it more punchy and it's shorter 13
it's eight weeks rather than 13 also I
think that I'm I'm thinking that
I want to focus in more precisely on the
skills that you will get and the
understanding you'll get I'm a little
bit less discursive and in this new
version I'm hoping that it will be like
a college finance course that teaches
the basics but I don't want to lose
sight of the moral values and the the
sense of purpose
I think that's absolutely essential
people need a sense of how they fit into
society why what I'm doing is good and I
think that in the in the area of Finance
there is a bit of a challenge because
Finance offers opportunities for sleazy
behavior and we have to warn people
about that and while they're studying
it's the time to discuss those issues
and it's a time to stiffen oneself
against the temptations I'm gonna take
another question this one has to do with
Africa this is from Leslie bull who
writes to ask some have argued that
Africa's recent economic boom is a short
term development brought on by rising
commodity prices that will inevitably
fall while others see it as a signal of
a new era of growth for the continent
where do you fall in this debate and
what do you predict for Africa's
economic future well I believe that
there is something fundamentally
important going on in Africa as it is in
the emerging world if you look at data
on GDP growth it's really all regions of
the world that have shown growth
substantial growth in recent decades
it's it's not a sudden short-lived
phenomenon it's it's a long-lasting
phenomenon and it's not confined to the
oil-rich countries I believe that it's
more due to a spirit that's a knowledge
that is spreading around the world the
world is more built around financial
capitalism than ever before we're
opening up stock markets
all over the world venture capital firms
are starting to practice in countries
where such a thing was unheard of
entrepreneurship is being encouraged
young people all over the world in every
country of the world are interested in
becoming entrepreneurs and there's an
understanding today that
entrepreneurship is where economic
growth begins you see this in Africa
you'll see this in the Middle East and
Latin America Asia all of the emerging
world is to varying extents but to a
substantial extent participating in what
I think historians will someday describe
is a historically important transition
so it's much broader than commodities
that's correct
and even those commodity rich countries
that are running out of oil these days
are actually many of them starting
sovereign wealth funds because they're
aware that they're going to run out of
oil and so instead of just consuming all
the oil they are investing for the
future which is a which is a quite a
increase step forward in enlightenment
that we've seen over the last decade or
two is it's it's a growing phenomenon
that people are appreciating that you
have to lock down secure the wealth and
not go through it fast that's part of
Finance I'm going to take a question
from Edie Hamilton who writes to say and
then ask inflation adjusted price
histories of stocks and homes show
bubbles very well he writes but these
histories are seldom shown to the people
do you think these histories are too
technical to deter bubble behavior by
people well I think bubble behavior is
here to stay so showing a plot of data
is helpful but most people will not be
deterred by it the problem is that
bubble behavior and this gets back to my
you mentioned my dispute with Eugene
at the no Valley them bubbles are kind
of hard to understand the it's it's a
phenomenon that confuses people
even in people who try very hard the
word bubble suggests that prices will
build for a while and then suddenly
burst and then it's done it's gone but
the world is constantly surprising us
and you you may see what seems to be the
end of a bubble and then surprisingly it
starts growing up again and so people
don't know what to make of it that's why
they don't seem to learn lessons after
the collapse of the housing bubble in
2006 I went from 2006 to 2012 in the
United States you might think that
people learned their lesson but no the
lesson that many of them learned is it's
gonna start all over again
this is a time when its prices are low I
better get into it that's the way so so
I don't think that we have learned and
and we're probably vulnerable to bubbles
going and I think probably even more
vulnerable to bubbles now in the
Information Age when we have internet
and communications and Twitter
minute-by-minute communications and and
when we have a sense of anxiety over
financial capitalism and the rising
inequality within it you get more and
more people who worry about bubbles and
that worry can be a self-fulfilling
prophecy and it can create those same
bubbles I mean to the extent that humans
remain human we're always going to be
subject to animal spirits and and so I
guess a question is is there any way to
subdue the the less rational aspects of
our our nature you know to advance
greater economic well-being for a
greater number of people well I've
written books about this and and not
only that there is an emerging group in
finance and economics who are studying
behavioural
economics which brings in human nature
to the a better understanding of human
nature into the analysis and it's not
just in economics departments people and
other social sciences are getting
interested we have neuroscience now in
the medical school we have people who
are studying they put people in fMRI
machines and study the brain patterns
when they're making financial decisions
and so I think that we're moving forward
we're understanding things better and we
can make better policy and we can create
opportunities for people to protect
themselves from bubbles in a better way
question from Vladimir Glinka who asks
and this is somewhat of a technical
question it appears to me what is the
difference between feedback theory and
heard behavior okay feedback they're
both elements of my theory of bubbles
feedback is price increases get people
excited and they buy and push the price
up again getting more people excited
that's feedback heard behavior refers to
a human tendency to follow others now
you might call that something like I can
see why he phrased that question but
heard behavior has a more of a
psychological element to it it's
something about how we judge the truth
it's often very difficult to know I'm
only one person I can't figure
everything else out I take for granted
that what other people are saying is
true and I might even feel some
emotional pull I want to be liked other
people are saying certain things so I'll
say them too that's heard behavior and
they're both elements of a properly
constructed theory of bubbles now if I'm
not mistaken you know Janet Yellen the
incoming chair of the Federal Reserve
I'm sure you've been asked this before
maybe she's asked you this question but
do you have any advice for her as she
yeah she sends to the job well I I trust
her judgement very well and yeah I've
talked to her
I think that we narrowly missed another
Great Depression this time around and we
need to use policies that recognize the
instability of the economy those wishful
thinking that a unregulated economy
would be stable well we know that in the
past in the 19th century before there
was much regulation the economy was very
unstable and we're learning and we ought
to be able to I think that what Ben
Bernanke did on his watch was very
helpful in reducing the amplitude of
fluctuations I think of her as similar
to Bernanke who will use good judgment
now she is inheriting a difficult
situation where aggressive monetary
policy has already been tried and the
the Fed balance sheet the Federal
Reserve System balance sheet is up to
something like four trillion dollars so
she's a little bit constrained she has
problems that are the legacy of this of
this crisis but I think she'll use good
judgment and going it's a matter of
keeping up and I know that she will do
this keeping up with the news and the
information as it evolves and I'm sure
she'll do that well I imagine you
watched or read about the president's
State of the Union speech the other
night there was a fair amount of
emphasis on economics one of President
Obama's key goals it seems to be is to
is to raise the minimum wage I don't
wonder if you have any thoughts on on
the minimum wage itself as a tool for in
some way mitigating the inequality and
problem I think one of the things that
recommends the minimum wage the most is
just that it is apparently politically
acceptable it it's probably not the
ideal way to deal with inequality first
of all it doesn't discriminate among
different it's teenagers who are the
people who
are paid below the minimum wage the most
and they're not typically worrying about
families it has a possibility of causing
layoffs it in one sense what you're
doing is telling employers we're gonna
tax you we're gonna make you pay instead
of making all of society pay but I think
that within limits a minimum wage may be
a good policy it's fallen behind it used
to be it hasn't kept up with inflation
and maybe they should index it to
inflation but on top of that I think
that maybe some other policies Edmund
Phelps as an economist and Nobel
prize-winning economist has recommended
that the government subsidize low income
employment and this would mean that all
the burden isn't being visited on the
people who are already employing low
income people but it would be spread out
among society and it could be more
finely tuned than than the minimum wages
now I have other proposals in my book
that which book well various books not
not this one
I had one called new financial order in
2003 and then subprime solution in 2008
in these books I argued that we should
make a plan for the distant future about
what we're going to do if inequality
gets much worse and I think that
ultimately the minimum wage is not going
to do the trick we need to have a policy
that is conditionally redistributed I'll
have to make this clear because some
people are so negative about
redistribution I'm not saying that we
shouldn't have substantial inequality
I'm saying because it's an incentive it
incentivizes people if we can't have
complete equality because then no one
would work hard because what's the point
you know if I make money it'll be taken
away from it has to be just and has to
respect people who have made money but
I'm worried that inequality is going to
get much worse in the future I don't
know that it will I'm worried already
young
people today in my class will ask me
what career is safe going forward and I
don't know I don't think anyone knows
because information technology is
automating such a high fraction of our
activities that it's really hard to say
and so I think we need a plan as a
nation and internationally because if
one nation makes a plan it's going to
have a problem if it's independent of
other nations because rich people will
leave that's what we saw when President
Ollanta and France raised the tax on
people with incomes over a million euros
to seventy five percent now we're seeing
rich people leaving France that's when
Gerard Depardieu you went to Russia yeah
well I last time I heard it was Russia
maybe it'll be Belgium they'll follow
they best offer but it's a problem that
it's a difficult problem just like
global warming is a difficult problem
because it's a worldwide problem we're
seeing inequality growing in most
countries of the world but I think we
have to start talking now and the talk
shouldn't be focused so much on
redressing past inequality we have to
think about the future and where where
we're going so is there is there a
particular initiative that that you
consider this point most worth pursuing
as a way to mitigate rising inequality
well I should say the president had
other proposals that he didn't explain
well in his State of the Union address
there was a was he called Myra a new
savings and incentive program that the
details have yet to come out I'm
impressed that he's thinking about what
a good source of our inequality
especially wealth inequality is that
many people don't save and so a program
that incentivizes them to save more
sounds very valuable he also talked
about pre-k education the research of Ed
Ziegler here at Yale and others have
shown that education of children
toddlers her
young children before kindergarten can
make a difference and there were other
ideas and I'm trying to think that might
in the President's speech that might
reflect on any well he also talked about
his innovation Institute's I don't know
if we used that word this time but he
has set up a Institute in Youngstown
Ohio to try to create high tech jobs
there this is an experiment that the
president is behind and I'm not sure
that it's working well yet but it we do
have to think about jobs and how we'll
create jobs and how we'll create jobs
and meaningfully growing sectors you are
so well known for your analysis of the
housing market I would be remiss not to
ask you your thoughts about housing in
let's focus on the United States right
now well I have my own home price
indices the Standard & Poor case-shiller
home price index and we just came out
with our new numbers so home prices
nationally went up 13.7 percent over the
last year that is quite a strong rate of
price increase and the question is what
is the outlook for that well we have
learned Carol case and I my colleague
and now other research has confirmed
that home prices show a lot of momentum
they go in the same direction
month after month maybe year after year
so with home prices going up so fast I
think and now the latest month in
November is down but that's because of
the season it's it's not the peak season
so I don't think that means anything I
think basically on a seasonally adjusted
basis home prices are going up rapidly
and they will likely continue to go up
on the other hand I think that I
wouldn't extrapolate another year of
13.7% home price increases it's not
going to be that fast I don't think
partly because we're entering the
tapering which Janet Yellen I think will
continue with that means that mortgage
rates might go up they're not gonna go
down or less likely to go down that's
gonna deter homebuyers and there's some
signs of a weakening world economy as
well so I just the other thing is I
don't think that we're in so strong a
bubble mentality as we were in say 2003
2004 I've been doing questionnaire
survey studies of home buyer behavior
and I don't see it it's not so I that's
my guess
home prices will keep going up but maybe
at 5% that over the next year not sure
exactly no one knows but but so that
means that people probably shouldn't and
shouldn't consider it urgent to buy em I
mean 5% is 5% you know on a $200,000
house that's $10,000 but you know you
can put your money in some other
investment you might make more so I
don't think people should rush to buy
into a housing market if they're ready
and they want to great but not to get
spooked by this so-called bubble right
now when I take a question from kana duo
Daru who asks given available
alternatives is gold the most reliable
and stable product to invest in well I
don't think reliable and stable is the
words I would use the gold has done very
well in the first decade of the 21st
century because economic anxiety has
been growing and people often flock to
gold when anxiety grows but it's very
volatile and I'm not I don't know how to
predict what it's going to do the
economy might be healing and and the
gold prices might fall dramatically tell
us briefly a little bit about the the
Nobel experience that you had when you
went to receive the award whether it's a
week-long Nobel week and it was it was
actually a lot of fun it was a
I know arrests but it I got to meet
other no ballasts including Jim Rothman
here at the Yale do you ever met him
before I hadn't met him no not before I
won the we were on we won the prize but
it was fun I had the opportunity to talk
with all these different noblest except
Alice Monroe the literature one was ill
and couldn't come but every other one I
met and it was that was great so we're
gonna wrap us up pretty soon um and take
a question from a Nicholas poo hole who
asks with a developed world in so much
debt relative to GDP isn't
hyperinflation the only way out I hope
you're wrong I think my sense is that
we're under control about it the
government has issued a lot of
high-powered money or reserves but
they've kept it in so that the money
supply actually hasn't gone up more than
historically they've the the Federal
Reserve pays interest on reserves which
causes member banks to prevent them from
lending it out and increasing the money
supply so it seems to be under control
Ben Bernanke has said that there's no
cause for alarm
and I I think that's right I'm not
alarmed about hyperinflation
but there there is a there are bad
scenarios that might be troublesome the
Fed has bought a lot of mortgage
securities and it's on its balance sheet
if the economy collapses again those
mortgage securities might not have good
prices and so that the Fed would then be
technically insolvent and we might have
to in effect bail out the Fed or they
could have it would have to bail itself
out by printing money but I don't think
that will happen I think it'll probably
be all right
so you're starting the Coursera course
on the 17th I believe you you recently
published finance of the goods
xiety write a book that will we'll be
using that course I think right
reports a book that I'm going to refer
to because it's a it's a book that I
wrote in the conjunction with this
course as a way of thinking about the
what's really on so many people's minds
is what does it all mean and are people
in finance good people or not well there
is no single answer to that some of them
are good and some of them are bad I want
my students to be the good the good ones
and I want to see them as contributing
to society on that note I want to thank
you so much for joining us to chat today
and I want to thank all of you for
watching at Yale live and hope that
you'll join us again next time
you